hi i'm madan maswati and i manage the
rise group at microsoft research where
we work on programming languages
software engineering formal methods and
high performance computing
i am very excited to welcome you to the
track on empowering software developers
and mathematicians with next generation
ai at microsoft research summit
when i was fresh out of grad school a
long time ago i happened to have dinner
with raj reddy it was just by pure
chance as many of you might know raj
reddy is a touring award winner and is
one of the early pioneers of ai
during the in dinner conversation he
casually mentioned something that has
struck with me to this day
he defined artificial intelligence as a
machine doing a task which if a human
did you would consider the human to be
intelligent
that way of thinking about ai has
profound implications
for me it provides a great thought
experiment to see how far we have come
with ai and how far we still have to go
for every a application imagine a human
performing the task but with exactly the
same performance
would we consider that human intelligent
would we trust the person with our
private stories
will we consider that person qualified
enough to work with us
on many dimensions such as image
recognition and natural language
processing we have come far
ai today can learn from vast amounts of
data exceeding human performance in a
variety of tasks
however on certain other dimensions such
as reliability predictability
correctness and trustworthiness we still
have long ways to go
such open challenges are what excites us
at microsoft research
some of us strongly believe that there
is a next generation of ai to build
one that combines the robust data-driven
capabilities of machine learning with
the deep logical reasoning of symbolic
systems
we also strongly believe that this new
power can be harnessed to empower humans
to achieve more
this track will showcase some of our
work on how we are innovating in this
new frontier
microsoft at its core is a software
company and it's home to the world's
largest developer ecosystems including
azure github and visual studio there's a
lot of emphasis at microsoft on how we
can design ai to empower software
developers and help them through the
development process from coding and
testing to reviewing code and merging
changes
this also brings out the socio-technical
aspects of software development we must
make sure that the systems we build are
improving developer productivity and
velocity
so it is important to measure the right
things and measure them the right way
as we evolve the next generation of
developer communities we must make sure
that these communities are safe secure
and inclusive
just as we have built over many decades
tools and techniques and ecosystems to
empower software developers
we are actually building equivalents
that enable mathematicians to achieve
more this is an exciting new area that
we are heavily investing in in this
track you will hear about the recent
advances in formalized mathematics
starting from a programming language for
math to automated tools for theory
improving this track will also showcase
our work in improving the performance of
machine learning systems which is
absolutely crucial for empowering
developers and mathematicians and so
much more
overall we have an exciting collection
of talks fireside chats and panels for
you we've brought together leaders from
github such as bobby dresser mala kumar
and ogidamour leaders from visual studio
such as amanda silver and neil
sundereson and many researchers and
practitioners from microsoft as well as
our close external collaborators such as
kevin buzzard from imperial college
london brian lyles from vmware and
margaret ian's story from university of
victoria with so many wonderful
perspectives this will be an exciting
program to explore how we are amplifying
and inspiring creativity in the work of
developers mathematicians and beyond